Comment gonfler un ballon sans souffler dedans ?
D’habitude, pour gonfler un ballon, nous
vidons l’air de nos poumons dedans.
Ou si on a la flemme, on utilise une pompe !
Le défi d’aujourd’hui va consister à gonfler un
ballon sans utiliser ni pompe ni poumon !
Pour cela, nous allons avoir besoin de ce matériel.
Une petite bouteille d'eau transparente
Un entonnoir
du vinaigre blanc et du bicarbonate de soude
On va tout d'abord venir gonfler le ballon pour détendre le caoutchouc
Voilà !
Puis, on va venir mettre du vinaigre dans la bouteille
Avec l'entonnoir, on va venir fixer le ballon comme ceci
et mettre à peu près une cuillère, une cuillère et demie de bicarbonate dedans
et un petit peu plus... et voilà !
La dernière étape consiste à fixer le ballon sur le goulot de la bouteille
Attention à ce que le ballon soit bien fixé et que celui-ci ne craque pas
Une fois cela fait, on va pouvoir verser le bicarbonate dans la bouteille
et on voit que le ballon se gonfle tout seul
Que s'est-il passé ?
Lorsque tu souffles dans
un ballon pour le gonfler,
tu le remplis d’air. L’air est un gaz invisible
présent partout autour de toi,
et que tu aspires pour respirer.
Quand on mélange le bicarbonate de soude
avec le vinaigre, une réaction chimique se
produit et créé un gaz : du dioxyde de
carbone, aussi appelé CO2. Ce gaz va remplir le
ballon, et donc le gonfler !
Le dioxyde de carbone est un gaz
qui permet aussi d’éteindre les incendies !
Aujourd’hui directement présent dans les
extincteurs, ça n’a pas été toujours le cas !
Il y a presque 150 ans, des « grenades
extinctrices » étaient utilisées pour éteindre
les feux de cheminées. Le principe était de les
jeter dans le feu pour l’éteindre. En
ce faisant, ces grenades en verre
éclataient et libéraient leur contenu sur les
flammes. Certaines de ces grenades comme celle que j'ai ici
étaient composées de plusieurs produits chimiques qui étaient
séparés les uns des autres. Lorsque qu’elle
éclatant dans les flammes, ces bouteilles libéraient ces produits
qui se mélangeaient et formaient
un gaz qui montait dans le conduit de
cheminée et ainsi éteignait le brasier.
Par souci d’efficacité et de sécurité,
ces grenades ont été remplacées depuis.
Merci d'avoir regarder cet épisode !
Et je te donne rendez-vous la semaine prochaine
pour répondre à une nouvelle question !